yeah the software is telling me I'm life
which I never really believed fully so
give me a quick message if I'm really
live here for the ICC streaming one hour
of blitz chess I hope yeah upstream for
one hour and 30 because I never won a
game in that particular session I hope
that doesn't that doesn't happen again
so I'm going to go for for the
five-minute pool and see what happens I
haven't played a game of chess today so
I hope I'm getting getting off to a good
start doing chess all day but not
playing chess let's see five minute pool
on the way I couldn't even watch the
shaam KO tournament today the dashing
off memorial I I saw that so one is game
against Mammadov and some oxy bind but
what and kramnik had a wild opening
against Anand but I didn't really look
at details I don't get a game yeah no I
get one against ego ah whose ego on
let's check that David straws David
Strauss this is an odor would I am I
don't say no no name and I don't know
this guy okay I'm going for a king's
indian and see what we get classical
Kings onion hi he goes with age three
yeah this is also a line that I
sometimes play mmm and then g3 even that
I have played this guys are copying me
nah not really it's not copying me but
how do you play you take I don't know
yeah I think Magnus Carlsen play the
draw today against um Micky Adams in our
inner we Lopez yeah that looks a lot
like a typical Kings Indian fianchetto
but I'm not totally sure about this how
this is played IAM maybe Ruby aid or
something okay nighty six takes takes he
has a higher so I'm getting getting my
book out out there hmm yeah Wesley so is
leading this tournament now which is
maybe a slight surprise given that he
had those difficulties in the US
Championships ok I'm going to take and
let's see there should be six maybe just
trying to develop him yeah why does
certainly a bit better that's not a very
exciting position for the black player
okay yeah I don't know do I go 97 here
for possible trades or not I can also
play c5 and b5 try to be trying to be
active I don't know this is great okay
let's do it c5 Bishop e3 and b5 and not
no okay wasn't sure what you were
thinking about he cannot possibly take
on f6 yeah Bishop f4 was the move that
troubled me but oh it takes uh-huh I am
okay maybe five now so that this is idea
i don't know I'd be sure before I always
have root b6 and I can cover the pond um
yeah that's a question about the
simultaneous event I had made a wrong
video announcement today talking about a
simultaneous event I had that last
Sunday yeah like eight days ago and well
there will be a new one but probably in
may then but this is only for icc
members yeah hi there mercury and some
you guys hear the final zoosk one or not
lot shinnick difficult to pronounce for
me i'm sorry if this is totally wrong um
okay he went 5 interesting move ha ok um
night h5 maybe this can be a problem
here right I don't know if he 5 was a
was so was a big problem here for me if
I can get to take on fo it should be
fine yeah this is just a normal blitz
session about one hour yeah I had one
one that lasted longer but this was one
of those where I didn't get a win in I
hope to break any kind of any kind of
bad streak immediately with a win yeah
can i play the Catalan room I can but
they don't really allow me that all of
the time I can try I can try what is
worth doing here I probably did not
think about night h5 yellow back to high
farm this is an Israel right so we are
very internationally set up here yes I
heard that cooling croucher passed away
I did not know him really in person um
well I don't know much about him to be
honest I had to I had one of his books
at least he wrote a book about the
Bishop f4 Queens gambit some years ago
okay I'm taking a
and while Knight b6 nagi to it's just
good for black I think and yeah Here I
am I think well I thought I can take a
fire but Sully will take b6 I see so
maybe just just the rook here right rook
a six to take a two could you play a
Petrov hmm Petrov is not one of the
openings that I do play I can I can
drive I can try but it's tricky yeah i
heard that Nigel did win the the
Thailand Open Bangkok I think open um
yeah that's an interesting tournament
this is open then thailand it's
something that I do consider to play
myself um the only reason i am not
having did not do that yet is that i
really hate flying so this is a terribly
terribly long flight Stonewall I think
I'm more comfortable with playing yellow
tube Irish White's I think I know who
you are enjoy the Blitz session do you
think the k-factor on Isis which as I
see is too high no i don't think so i
think it blitz it should be a pretty
high k-factor the ups and downs are I'm
funny yes I saw a well that what Nigel
wrote there about women and chess or
women playing chess that is something
that is out of new and chairs magazine
he wrote that in the latest issue and I
read it when it was on on the on the new
in chess in the new in chess magazine
and I think we had this um we had this
this issue in a broadcast last week and
well the thing is I don't I don't have
any scientific knowledge there about
this about this issue but what I do
think is that what they what they wrote
there in the German newspapers at least
there was a new ticket and was a was
something in the Spiegel one a very big
German news site and what they wrote
there was frankly speaking just nonsense
they they didn't really think about the
subject or wrote about the shot tech
they just said that this is kind of
sexist nonsense and it isn't it really
isn't um i think that nigel is probably
in some way right but it's um but it's
something that is very unpopular
suggesting that people in some way are
different being Adam like I'd like the
sexist being different on people I don't
know being different that our I don't
know from from from countries from
different countries or so on people are
different they are not better not worse
but they are different and this is
definitely something that is tricky
nowadays to say okay because well
because of political correctness young
people want to believe that everybody is
equal and so on which is too but they
are not the same okay let's see what am
I doing here I've sacrificed the
exchange let's go here I don't want to
trade stuff
yeah the Petrov is an okay opening for
sure what about this I can't go Bishop
d5 here but he has Quincy form looked it
to Maddy's got checks down and you have
to play yeah let's let's be best bit
quickly i only have 30 seconds and i
have no problem here with the with the
exchange down a very decent compensation
I don't don't really see me winning this
on on on position but maybe there are
some some ideas each five pusher page
three okay let's do that trying to
irritate him a little bit I which he can
go all the way to a 500 that that's not
that wasn't a particularly great idea
what did i do him I don't really see
what to do now ah oh then I should have
just made a drawdown I tried I tried a
little bit tried a little bit a little
bit too much there okay so let's see um
the resolution of your stream is too
high for wing and owners genes could you
make a small resume nabol yeah I don't
know that's something for the ICC guys
to say I really don't really don't know
i'm not a huge am an expert on twitch
okay so let's see here black rubble
let's see we gotta be got a really low
pass yeah there is the the long castles
variation on of course 93 and long
castles in the Petrov it's just one of
one of many lines nothing known
particularly particularly threatening
yeah hmm this guy here let's see what we
get is probably not falling into the ark
Noah trap with Queen d45 losing a piece
c3 is a is a draw though if I take it
Queen default blundering blundering a
piece
arrays are short game yeah yeah I'm
about about the subject of here Nigel
short is playing a funny match against
far off just next weekend so looking
forward to that it seems that normal he
has kind of kind of irritated here by
this by this opening I really wonder
what he what he is thinking now c3 is
the way to go quindi 45 is blundering
stuff okay so maybe just Bishop d7 here
right I'm taking Queen edge five maybe
is this and this is something hmm should
be seven takes takes Queen age five okay
I'd it's not a not a huge problem takes
takes Queen age five it is an issue i
have d5 strange stuff
now I have not played the hot variation
on anh Li chest I saw that chest network
was was playing that recently but it's
just nonsense the pawns just just win so
it's a it's completely pointless game ok
so we traded here the rook there on
ahead yeah this is a one point yeah he
can get this this check in when f seven
he had Queen B 5 but I didn't think it
sets a huge problem what do I go here g6
or d5 I was thinking d5 actually so
let's go d 5 I don't know I thought I
thought that the the pawns should win
this but ok it's not I mean I didn't
invest time on this it's not a very
important point of chess education this
variation ok so what do we have here and
I don't know is moving a screen a ton of
times Queenie seven maybe for winning
this porn I really want the pawn yeah
and I will get it I think next move I
take it 27 was ok yeah but d5 was strong
right I mean I had 95 next an idea for
six next 27 was playable sure but this
is a nice position
okay i will take now hear this let's
take yeah well he gasps yeah he's not
playing at the time of day he's usually
playing during during the day so we'll
probably know all the gas in my in my
life stream now probably his playing
half and half of the day and the other
half of the day is practicing rook
against rook trying to find a win them
yeah so what is this now I'm going to
take now here right how do I keep keep
my porn okay I'm taking c5 there is
possibly yeah but okay I have before
night a three I can play B form I'm not
well developed though this is something
to not forget now it should be fine
though
yeah holy gas is my personal nemesis on
the ICC I haven't fantastically bad
score against him like I don't know 15
losses two wins or something which is
really really bad I mean it is it is
just it sounds bad and it is bad I mean
he's the better player I'm totally ready
to acknowledge that but I just I just I
mean a blitz player at least I'm totally
ready to to to admit that but my score
is just it's just not there i had never
get anywhere yes this rook against rook
endgames and stuff i don't know i don't
i don't know what i do in those games
okay rook a7 seems to be on the cards
huh that's awkward
yeah it's not so easy to win this
position at least I don't see it you
might try to attack my be pawned I have
before but that's not a move I like to
play and not i particularly like to play
here Knight b6 maybe I a lot no not
completely sure how to play this look a
7 rook e8 and I White's night is not
doing much yeah all the gas is very well
known on the ICC for this time plays and
so on so I'm not they're not the only
one suffering against him to be
perfectly honest I once made made I once
just for purely entertainment purposes i
did a search on in the icc games
database and i looked for all the games
that Nakamura played against Allah gas
and he totally destroys him so it was
very it was very very entertaining to
see Nakamura destroy my nemesis at one
at one day I should try try that myself
but i usually don't manage ok so where
do I go now knight c6 Bishop c7 looks
really awkward night a six kind of funky
yeah that was a good news it was a good
news
yeah let's get let's get forward jam and
possibly 95 still less bishops his own
alright still a bit tricky and I only
have 30 seconds what did i do here what
did i do here with my time 30 seconds
that's not good but where's his route
going to d5 probably let's try to
prepare 93 rookie one mate that would be
cute oh I don't can't get this in okay
rook activation time now I mean I'm in a
good situation yeah it's just that I
have no time for should probably okay
that's good he takes its time as well so
it's it's good news check him here check
him again and then there cannot take b5
now and now this night is hanging there
okay okay maybe I get the beep on anyway
no what did i do here I'm blundering
like my good pon de anza for okay
yeah there was a pre moon fest I went on
time who I did not know what Gail what
was going on there okay so I want to
look at them um let's check where are
many many questions there um something
there yeah how to improve there's a
question you back watch how to improve
tactical on tactical play and your
tactical awareness and it's not so easy
actually um what you can do is of course
you can do you can practice calculation
regularly yeah just the pure calculation
point of things um there are some other
things that you can do you can try to
play a little bit more aggressively in
some situations let's say in blitz chess
yeah just do something a little bit more
active and maybe trying to change a
little bit of the opening repertoire
that leads to sharper sharper positions
and there's also studying games by very
dynamic active players now you can go
back in history look at stuff by and by
oh yeah invite all or you have some some
of the classic aggressive players let's
see do I get some good game in now the
game before that wasn't that great yeah
practicing calculation um you should you
can solve technical puzzles there on
various levels for simple stuff relative
relatively simple stuff you can use
tactic trainers online resources on or
you can um use use books of course there
are many good books on calculation I can
especially recommend the books by by
jakub our God they are really excellent
for calculation also for other things
yeah playing blitz for tactics is a good
idea it's not bad
if you if you want to improve your
short-term tactical vision then playing
blitzes excellent it's not so great for
improving your own calculation abilities
on in let's say in complicated
situations where there are many many
options what is happening here I have to
check this Bishop before no we went
there ok I don't know that that opening
here I mean as some of that once but g5
or how do you play that g5 funny line
there's a question do you think the
moral gambit is playable where the sea
45 and do you mean the the Danish gambit
like e-40 5d four playable it is it's
not leading to much but you can
certainly play it some it's it's about
equal ok what is this so if I'm taking
push-up t2 now recorded his got some
some quite substantial pressure here
maybe Bishop here attacking the d6 bond
tricky what now I can go g3 but I'm not
sure that I want that should be too
maybe let's go Bishop t2
yeah I do have a chessboard but I don't
use it very often i do i'm ninety-five
percent or so of work on the computer
maybe more my favorite unsound gambit I
don't know I don't play on sound gambits
I know the hell Dane heck yes it's some
some French line i think but nothing
great i think yeah so what about this
game this is an interesting interesting
position he has some played in a very
active way but i have some have some
strategic gains in this position some
play against d6 i have g5 as a nice pawn
that limits plex play I don't know this
looks like nice for white i think i can
try whoopty to look T 1 hmm and now I
don't know does he have a for a three
maybe he has right maybe he has a for
him okay so he tries to do what exactly
Bishop f4 I don't know okay I'm just
putting this on the default yeah yeah I
played some unsound gambits of course in
them in on on on CH s cube in those in
those crazy tournaments sure sure sure
now that this is this this is a
different situation you have to win
quickly in those tournaments when I was
when I was played
Oh
hmm interesting what about this check
there isn't this good yeah that should
be good right gaining the gaming the
bishop pair here and asking him what he
did that's about the d6 porn should do
that yeah now he ate let's take that
yeah and I will give the exchange back
here of course to get get through to
break through rook takes the six just
for one I have a pawn then but a very
nice extra porn and there was a question
if there is a natural limit for some
people and if there is a limit and what
what it is I think that 1800 is a rating
level that is reachable for probably
almost everybody but it is something
that is not possible to get without very
intense training in cases where you are
not like a super talented player there
are people who who really have an
enormous talent for chess they get get
to very high rating levels without doing
anything or very little at same and in
other cases it's a matter of hard work
yeah I was angling for that um rookie
five ago bishop is free i keep my porn
and control this was more valuable to me
than the other position with the
exchange where he could struggle um yeah
I think there is there was a discussion
recently on reddit if there is a natural
limit for some some players some people
in chess and there was some person
posting that 1,600 is what he can get
and not more and whatever he does he
tried everything whatever
and I agree that there there is
something about this that there there is
a kind of limit for everybody but it's
not 1600 nobody's limited 1600 so it's
definitely higher how to tell what it is
but it's higher than that given the
given that you really put in time sure
what the guy is doing is this a
disconnect or something I don't know
when it's check there no wasn't now we
played ok ahead Bishop deform it should
be 3 i'm not sure about what I should do
yeah I can put this up as well Bishop f4
bit should be three sm fine and I need
the King anyway I can play you for next
wide gamer for the Mora or something
Bishop f4 ok let's put this up it is
clear if someone wants to get to a
rating level let's say of two thousand
and he really has very little natural
talent for the game that has to invest
hours and hours and hours and but then
it is possible I mean it is really this
game is is so rich in possibilities and
and all kinds of things that you can
learn I mean not just really i don't
know i mean learning in terms of looking
at stuff and trying to really remember
things like like patterns especially
yeah this is nothing that that comes
like out of the blue knowing patterns
knowing how let's say a particular game
was played and well I very often come
across situations in games where think
okay this is like a game I don't know
and the actually in Kappa Blanca with to
tempe up or something and this is stuff
that anybody can learn it's just a
matter of time yeah for some people for
some people it's easier to remember
things like that and for some it is it's
trickier but you can
definitely get there anybody can get
there just a matter of how much time are
you willing to invest and this is often
the the deal ok so I'm going to I'm a
bit surprised that he allowed me this
protected corner only forward ok now I'm
going look on the G file trying group
chief form um yeah i can give you can
check me i can go if five but that
blender stuff can also do this and put
the bishop on d5 that's also good idea
it looks really quite nice yeah nowadays
nowadays the the possibilities are
really great yeah in terms of improving
in chess you have you have great books
yeah compared to what we had let's say
in the late eighties um I submit earlier
he resigns that um you have great books
you have videos you have YouTube you
have things like the ICC online chat
service great stuff really great stuff
so um nowadays you have order order all
the ideas right there in the internet
let's say our own books of course a
serious question um what would the ideal
clock salute see what would be your
ideal clock situation for a game well it
depends of course my preferred blitz
time control online is three plus one
yeah someone writes that finds oops
wrong three plus one I think this is
good the three plus two is the official
feeder blitz time control + 3 + 2 is of
course also fine online but you can just
move quicker with pre moves so I think
three plus one is totally ok this is
even on average probably leading to
quicker games than the 50 time control
so it's not that people could complain
that this is not a blitz chess anymore
yes I've got the Grandmaster rapper to
our books but I
and cannot say that I read them the book
on top yeah that's DVD for volume to
where you're right okay I'm going for
you guys wanted to have some kind of
attacking game or some kind of gambit
okay I wanted to play the Bangko but now
you get get the Trump also interesting
um yeah you say one stream where you
play outside of irregular reputa yeah I
can do that actually why not it's a
funny thing but this thing is already 30
minutes and let's do that next week next
week I'm going to play an out of
character out of character stream okay I
don't know this opening at all actually
is it six a move I think we should be
success is something here that looks
really weird right let's try that the
Grandmaster repertoire books arm I are
excellent of course but they're
difficult to handle I think so I mean
it's it's difficult to learn because
they are so complicated sometimes I
really wonder why I mean I just
sometimes think that less is more right
or something simpler would be a would be
easier okay so what is what is this
situation yeah it's kind of strange do I
go e 5 I have a very funky looking night
on on d6 the night there that looks
strange but maybe I can play let's let's
see maybe I can play the F porn play
night f7 or something okay it's going
for 92 f 2 I don't know f5 is an idea
now I think come on Rick I almost bed
night at 5 f-5 makes make sense
there's a question a source to learn
Bishop e3 94 in the night often that's
an interesting question this is
currently almost the main line against
the Bishop e3 variation in the night off
hmm I don't know if they have it in a
book there's a book by under easy on
saavn under easy on i think but i'm not
i'm not totally sure if if it has this
this line on the other hand you know
nowadays mmm if you are if you are a
player who's interested in in such a
complex opening as the night off ya then
well get yourself a good engine decent
computer and do a database crunch and
write it on your own I know it sounds a
bit it sounds a bit strong but why not
yeah nowadays with computers you have
all the all the tools that you need and
why why should you come to other
conclusions then then the then the
people writing the books yeah just look
yourself just look for yourself very
often um the things that I presented in
the books are mostly just the number one
lines by the computers is really the
case for example if you look at those
books by babasab rook they are great but
if you look at them closely most of the
time he just quotes the number one the
first line of Houdini if you really
check the books with Houdini and all the
neville novelties that he's giving their
all the number one moves by Houdini
there are only some very rare exceptions
where he's getting in something that the
computer is is disliking so there's
really no big well you can do it
yourself so just trying to make your own
theory let's say look at the games and
try to find new ideas yourself I think
it's it's doable
yeah I'm trying to talk r inside player
when I was chatting away let's see ya b5
he had put this Bishop down on e six
which is looking nice but well I don't
know what it's doing there I'm sorry I
need some water yeah boy have the opens
up the position mmhmm yeah I can play a
form I'm not sure if this is any good
dumb and let's do that that's at least a
little bit more interesting pin then
checking I'm sorry hmm how long do I let
them how long do I let let the computer
run for four move hmm I cannot really
tell it's a it really depends and really
depends how complex the position is ok i
try to open up the queenside here
there's really a question about the
water that I'm drinking it's funny I
usually really drink tap water filtered
tap water but I'm very often on doing my
grocery shopping in one of those some I
don't know how it is called in English
one of those markets that specializes in
organic organic food is this the right
word and they had had a water they have
kind of a kind of weird stuff that I
wanted to try out it's just water you
know but I was curious it just really
just water
just a weird brand um yeah what what
many top players do is they really am
yeah look at the computer games computer
versus computer which sounds kind of
weird but it does make some sense some
weird sense um okay he's trying to push
his pawns of the bots and trying to win
this pawn sorry and I will manage but
it's still not a really great position
now how do i do that takes hmm yeah the
bishop tends to be better in this type
of position with with them passed pawns
yeah health food store maybe that's
that's that's also good I don't know I
really have no idea what it is called in
in English um so what is this exactly
my back rank looks absolutely terrible
but I don't see how I use it it I look
somewhere if I cannot check and they
cannot take maybe I can can approach
king of eight rookies seven yeah the
bloody a porn I know the a porn is a
problem takes takes Bishop e7 a 695
maybe looks looks very difficult at
least my king is relatively active so
maybe I can do something here but
probably not on
now I played this badly right I really
played this bad lame it's called 14
seconds oh ok at least I think I'm
getting a draw at least ok so let's see
hmm can I win now probably not right I
can win on time but I don't really think
I can do something on on position here
night back to a seven I can go here
maybe night to before
no going back is not going to work Jim
oops okay it's a draw okay I can never
draw sorry woods and now I know our
enough time wow that was funny okay um
let's see i didn't i didn't really
really had a look that it was a draw I
tried to find a win but I didn't find
one ok so I'm going if one hour for for
a change so which tournaments do you
plan on playing this year hmm yah that's
it's easy I'm going to play um so I'm
going to play um a small tournament
actually um plate or organized by my own
chess club the beginning of May this is
not a very spectacular event it's just a
local event um but it's buy my own Club
so I'm going to participate um then I'm
going to play an um an open tournament
in in Poland in in July which is
certainly interesting never been to
Poland so curious ok we have a this
assistant must be right here see for he
lost lots of time there now opened up
the position so I really have a hard
time to believe that should be tricky
for like 93 I guess why can start with
capturing and then 93 and it's probably
both good let's start with taking
um there was a question about
correspondence play yeah well I don't
really know I mean nowadays
correspondence claim mostly means um
yeah who's got the better computer
always better in better with with
handling I'm the engine and I don't see
much point in that ready it was a very
interesting thing in the past of course
but nowadays I don't see the point it's
mostly a waste of time and what is this
I can check here right I can also start
with 95 let's start with this this looks
rather rather problematic would like to
put it mildly
yeah black skin looks it looks very
shaky um so let's check Knight f6 no I
can also check on a try edge on age 5 I
can check on a four they all do make
some some kind of sense checking here
bishop here it's not going to win but
the check yet looks really problematic
right Nyjah six hmm I can check on a 40
of seven mmm I don't know if Bishop g6
is winning it doesn't doesn't seem so
convincing
hmm not seeing a clear win in this
position
huh amazing this isn't this isn't so
this isn't so this isn't so clear hmm
okay maybe I should have done something
different this doesn't look totally
clear really isn't you should be h5
maybe wasn't so great okay so i wanted
to go here for possible 95 queen d 3
it's still not easy at all for black to
play this but it feels like I should
have had something better I really
should have had something better
it's a question about the UM the Rue La
Paz y white is going for that yeah
Bishop b5 it does some it does have a
number of points in the Rue topes you
keep the tension far far more how longer
then in in many other lines in the in
the rib sorry in the in the open games
sorry they are like in the in the
Italian game for example and this is why
it is played so often it's no one this
no it's no coincidence that nowadays the
the Berlin defense the Berlin Wall is so
popular because they are black very
often gets to remove the important e4
pawn quickly and I'm just taking this
right oh I don't know what what is this
ok I'd still it still was good for white
i think but i probably should never have
allowed him to Castle young multicast
Multi multi cast is Miss mystery I don't
know he was labeled at the comp then
labeled back as human you never know
it's is tricky someone says that Ileana
also was an engine this is a possible
she was or this handle always was very
slow but I'm also slow sometimes and I'm
not not an engine if you never know ok
I'm Queen to be five huh I don't want to
trade Queens really
I would like to have the night on d3 but
I don't see how yeah that's not
something that i particularly like to
play
trying to amuse the night it's equal
material right maybe I should have taken
I don't know maybe I should have taken a
bishop t4 is a move ok didn't go for
that
totally miss played that from that
opening is really disgusting that I
didn't manage to refute this completely
the opening was a total disaster right
that I didn't win outright is kind of
embarrassing now you definitely have an
increased heart rate of you if you play
those quick time controls it definitely
happens but it's not like I'm on 200 or
something that's that it's not really
important enough to get to that not sure
what he's doing here this looks in the
next strange way of playing but it's
still sit okay for him of course still
it wrong
it's a draw around so some way for me to
win I'm getting there right so it should
be a win let's check yeah after G 383 is
winning yeah and that's it going to win
the Jeep oh wow so I win this after all
that this wasn't really deserved I
should have should have refuted the
opening yeah the the the Berlin defense
to the ROI is really am an opening you
know it has it has this boring
reputation and this is this is not this
is not entirely unjustified it is
sometimes really a bit boring if you
watch it and grand master chess but this
is also because they have such great
technical play if you like positions
that are rather simplified yeah not this
kind of not know crazy chest you know
then this is not a bad idea here if you
if you and you can play it with very
little and theoretical knowledge what is
this year it's not playing this guy this
is danielle de Vaca toro funny this is a
good year is almost a 2,600 player I
played him in in Bilbao last year in the
European club cup it is really low rated
here for a good GM surprising ok we have
a some kind of reversed or some kind of
tirage tirage defense what is this I can
take here right Queen takes 95
okay this looks really not like much to
write home about four white queen 85
queen 85 queen bee six maybe I can
always claim that i have this Bishop
there on g7 that looks nice 96 now let's
trade stuff this is this is equal this
is probably equal well forgot to take on
c3 okay I really forgot that I wanted to
take them I hope this doesn't come to
bite me the other c6 pawn is weakish if
I go look the eighth as Quincy three
check okay oh that's now that's not a
good news i don't think so really long
castles I don't believe in that one bit
my attack should be something here I
have the beef out here how is same
playing this now c5 c4 is also in the
mix c5 Bishop g5 and that's good for
Black Sea 5c four
or AFI therefore let that both seems
seems fine that's a question which
toplay and your opinion plays most
consequently for win no matter the color
or tournament situation hmm I don't know
if yours if this if top layer means like
top 10 it's difficult I mean they were
very professional about them about the
games there are some people who really
go for ya go all in every game if you
are looking at let's say top 40 to 50
like Richard report for example from
Hungary he's playing funny openings and
yeah what is he doing here I mean this
is a very tricky situation another set
but you have to move at some point yeah
of the top 10 um I think ya real report
is really fighting like a madman yeah he
always has wacky openings um and there
are some people on below that yeah here
I can take and place you for that was my
idea or the immediate see for this is
maybe even better
a player who's for example very
interesting to watch and it's not he's
not very much in focus is grandmas and
easy piano he's now playing for the
German Federation I'm formally and
played for Romania and he's a big
fighter he's always playing open events
and he has to win games and he's really
playing interesting fighting chest also
knighted yeah if we look for German
players he is also fighting her in
almost every game so um there are many
players there but Carla camera they
definitely try to win their games yeah
it's not that they play play boring
stuff absolutely not yeah an understood
a very strong player absolutely okay so
I thought quinte for here maybe I am any
good moves Queen somewhere to a two
would be great but let's let's do this
that's not bad Quincy to Queenie five is
definitely good for black not quite sure
how good but it is good for me there's
Queen a one now c3 and Queen a five in
the game so I'm going to take here for
Queen a three check threat the White
King is just far too open long castles
wasn't a really great idea as I as I
said so let's get everything in the game
um okay so don't tell me I'm not winning
here that would be crazy Quincy three
rupee one and Queen 85 in other cases
um Quinn a fire right Queen a 2 also in
sec we nee to marry come let's go Queen
804 Queenie to check yeah but she is
still a force definitely mini lost those
two matches against against Carlton but
well this is nothing particularly I mean
everybody loses against cars and there's
nothing particularly bad about that so I
got a winning in this in this final game
I think he this long Castle smooth was
ur was kind of kind of kind of very
risky um ok so we are already through
here funny mm-hmm funny it always time
time flies ok I'm promising um funny
session next week yeah on April the 27th
I think trying to do some some some
unusual openings for my for my game yeah
I'm not playing fishy stuff don't get me
wrong but I'm trying to do something
something something else ok guys i hope
you enjoy it some some good games and
some good chatter i hope you enjoyed the
enjoyed my my bantering and and stuff
that i that i was speaking about thanks
guys up to next week